[Musique]
bonsoir à tous faut-il aider à mourir ce
qu'il le souhaite c'est une question
vertigineuse infiniment complexe si on
répond oui immédiatement surgissent tout
un tas d'interrogations elles sont
simples qui pour donner la mort à qui a
seulement certains malades à partir de
quel âge comment éviter les dérives
aujourd'hui l'aide au suicidé
l'euthanasie sont passifs de poursuites
pénale faut-il légaliser nous vous
proposons ce soir un numéro spécial
d'état de santé pour tenter d'éclairer
ce débat avec nos invités nos reportages
ce sera chacun ensuite de se faire son
opinion comme d'ailleurs doivent le
faire les 185 membres de la Convention
citoyenne qui se sont réunis depuis des
semaines à la demande d'Emmanuel Macron
et qui rendront leur conclusion début
avril on verra ensuite s'il y a
effectivement une évolution de la loi on
va en parler avec nos invités je suis
très heureuse de recevoir Sarah Dechy
bonsoir psychiatre à la PHP présidente
du Centre national des soins palliatifs
et de la fin de vie vous étiez à la tête
du département des soins de support à
l'Institut Gustave Roussy bonsoir
Jonathan Denis vous êtes le président de
l'Association pour le droit de mourir
dans la dignité évidemment une
association très active dans ce débat et
vous aviez accompagné plus d'une dizaine
d'années précisément votre père dans
cette démarche vous nous direz tout à
l'heure si ça a été le réflexe de votre
engagement associatif bonjour ou plutôt
bonsoir Mathias Savignac président de la
mutuelle MGEN la MGEN qui a plusieurs
services de soins palliatifs à travers
le territoire vous avez aussi mené une
consultation interne auprès de tous vos
membres pour éclairer ce débat certaines
façons et finalement il y a une
conclusion collective qui a manifeste
que nous avons produit et qui vise à
promouvoir les soins palliatifs et
l'aide à mourir
soin palliatifs et d'activent à mourir
ce sont évidemment des notions sur
lesquelles on va beaucoup s'arrêter
bonsoir Martin spranzy merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous maîtresses de
conférences en histoire philosophie et
éthique des sciences à la Faculté de
médecine de l'Université Versailles
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines et j'ajoute
que vous êtes aussi consultante en
éthique consultante d'éthique auprès de
l'AP-HP je veux tout de suite vous
demander quelque chose parce que c'est
vrai qu'on réfléchit depuis des années
grâce notamment à la DMD assez question
plus précisément je sais pas depuis
plusieurs dizaines d'années mais parce
que dans le fond notre rapport à la vie
et à la mort a considérablement changé
ça n'a plus rien à voir avec ce qu'il
était à la fin du 19e ne serait-ce qu'à
ce moment-là tout à fait je pense que la
médecine est prise un peu à son propre
piège aujourd'hui parce qu'elle a été
elle a tellement de succès et elle a
augmenté l'espérance de vie depuis 19
de 15 ans on vit plus longtemps mais on
vit en souffrance un cinquième au dessus
de 85 ans sont un père d'autonomie
importantes le cinquième des personnes
au-dessus de 85 ans et ça c'est une
première raison une deuxième raison qui
me paraît plus lié à une question à la
fois psychologique et morale c'est que
la médecine avec sa précision du
pronostic du diagnostic rend un certain
nombre de malades des les mets dans une
position de condamné à mort dans lequel
ils n'ont plus la possibilité de
s'accrocher à quelques quelques petites
espoirs quel qu'il soit il y a une
troisième chose peut-être c'est une
frustration qui a créé justement par
rapport au succès de la médecine
c'est-à-dire dans l'opinion commune la
médecine
peut guérir toujours et certaines fois
mais elle peut pas guérir et donc il y a
une un contraste très important alors
que quand la médecine ne guérissait pas
et c'était le cas juste à jusqu'à la
deuxième guerre mondiale
de la médecine finalement ont un peu
nous ont un peu piégé dans ce rapport à
la mort mais enfin il y a quand même des
certitudes collectives c'est ça qui est
très frappant c'est que l'opinion
l'opinion lorsqu'on l'interroge et
depuis longtemps d'ailleurs depuis
quelques années sur cette question bien
elle est assez tranchée elle est
massivement favorable à une évolution de
la loi qui permette effectivement plus
de liberté et nous sommes allés
interroger à regarder des Français et
massivement à une exception près et bien
ils sont favorables à ce qu'on fasse
évoluer la loi
l'euthanasie ça devrait être accepté
pour que les gens puissent choisir comme
ils veulent de quelle façon ils veulent
mourir en fait parce que c'est leur
liberté ça permet de mourir sans
souffrir des personnes qui ont déjà
bien avancé dans l'âge qui se retrouvent
dans des situations de santé très
dégradées là je pense que c'est tout à
fait légitime je suis pas d'accord avec
on attend Nassi parce que notre avis
les partenariaux
pas les médecins par un médicament que
le bateau
[Musique]
la fin de vie ça représente pour
certains
des douleurs de la difficulté de la
solitude et que il y a aucune raison il
y a aucune raison d'endurer si on peut
partir avant et qu'on a les idées saines
et le cerveau bien fait si on a envie de
partir je trouve que on devrait pouvoir
être accompagné j'ai pu connaître des
personnes qui ont beaucoup souffert à la
fin de leur vie et qui n'avait pas de
possibilités réelles d'y mettre fin
alors qu'elles auraient aimé de devoir
aller en Suisse ou en Belgique je crois
pour un suicide assisté alors qu'en
France on est quand même la 7e puissance
mondiale
je me dis que c'est il y a un problème
et qu'il faut faire quelque chose je
trouve qu'effectivement il y a une
sangle d'inégalité devant devant la mort
si elle arrive et qu'on est complètement
grabataire qu'on a plus le sens de la
vie qu'on est tout seul qui a plus
personne qu'on ne nourri par sonde enfin
quel est l'intérêt de la vie quel est le
sens de la vie dans ce cas là en tout
cas en ce qui me concerne moi j'en ai
absolument rien à faire je n'en veux pas
de cette mort là c'est clair je vais
déjà pas de l'EHPAD alors imaginer
je n'en veux pas de cette mort là je
trouve que c'est très représentatif de
ce que pensent les Français ou les gens
en bonne santé quand ils pensent à ces
questions juste une docteur Dechy
question dites-nous tout de suite le
suicide assisté l'euthanasie quelle est
la différence dans les deux
l'intentionnalité est de la mort
survienne à la différence d'autres
dispositifs de la loi aujourd'hui comme
les citations profondes et contenues
jusqu'au décès qui a une intentionnalité
de d'endormir en soulageant la
souffrance en revanche on le suicide
assisté à la personne elle-même
s'administre le comprimé ou la substance
qui va entraîner la mort alors que dans
l'euthanasie c'est une tierce personne
qui le fait donc la différence c'est que
on est actif soi-même dans le suicide
assisté par des presque par définition
mais on vous a donné le matériel pour le
faire c'est cela c'est une tierce
personne qui intervient et ça sachant
que la vraie question est d'être actif
soi-même dans la prise de décision dans
la demande de soins et dans la demande
de soins dès le début de la maladie et
pas uniquement en fin de vie alors c'est
vrai que
quand on pense à la fin de vie tout un
chacun se dit j'ai pas envie de finir
grabataire j'ai pas envie de subir des
souffrances épouvantables je veux qu'on
finir vite
d'autant quand on nous a donné
effectivement un pronostic de cancer de
maladie
incurable qu'est-ce que vous répondez
vous qui accompagnez précisément les
personnes en fin de vie qu'est-ce que
vous dites à ceux qui bien portant se
disent ben oui Jean finir
je pense que ce qu'on leur dit est
d'abord une vérification d'information
sur la situation je suis frappé sera
avant tout le reste et peut-être
surprenant parce que le rôle d'un
médecin est d'abord de soigner mais je
pense que il y a une vraie question déjà
c'est de savoir de quoi on parle je suis
frappée dans les témoignages que vous
avez montré que qu'aucune personne ne
mentionne l'existence des droits actuels
de fin de vie et par ailleurs que
beaucoup renvoient ce qui est bien
naturel à des expériences et à des
expériences souvent extrêmement
douloureuses et je voudrais juste vous
donner un chiffre sensationnel Findus en
palliatif a fait en octobre un sondage
sur 1000 personnes de la population
française et j'ai plus de 18 ans il ne
s'agissait pas d'évaluer l'opinion des
Français par rapport à la loi il
s'agissait d'évaluer leurs connaissances
de la loi actuelle il n'y a que 15% des
personnes interrogées qui savaient
répondre correctement à 6 à 8 des
questions sur les 8 points majeurs des
dispositifs que sont les directives
anticipées la personne de confiance elle
sait bien son profonde et le droit au
refus de soin et donc on a un déficit
d'information important qui laisse la
place et qui coexistent avec une
importance des croyances des
représentations des expériences et c'est
une des premières choses qui est
importante c'est d'arriver à savoir ce
que la personne qui va décider pour elle
c'est de sa situation de ses droits et
de sa situation médicale c'est
passionnant ce que vous dites parce que
il y a une méconnaissance profonde du
système actuel la loi classe lyonneti
encadre la fin de vie elle avait créé
précisément des nouveaux droits elle
remonte à 2016 alors on va tout de suite
justement remédier peut-être en partie
modestement à cette méconnaissance en
faisant le point sur ce que dit la loi
regardez cette infographie et on se
retrouve juste après
[Musique]
en France 4 lois régissent
principalement la fin de vie la loi
Kouchner en 1999 garantit à chacun
l'accès aux soins palliatifs en 2002
elle va plus loin en établissant la
notion de droit des malades et évoque le
droit d'avoir une fin de vie digne en
2005 la loi Léonie la toute première a
traité spécifiquement de fin de vie elle
introduit l'interdiction de
l'obstination des raisonnable ou
acharnement thérapeutique et reconnaît
le droit d'arrêter tout traitement elle
instaure aussi la mise en place des
directives anticipées une déclaration
faite par le patient pour exprimer ce
qu'il accepte ou non pour sa fin de vie
limitée ou arrêter les traitements être
réanimés être placé sous respirateur
artificiel ou tout autre souhait sous la
forme d'un document écrit daté et signé
elles peuvent être enregistrées dans le
dossier médical ou simplement confié au
médecin ou à des proches qui les feront
valoir le le moment venu en 2016 la loi
classe Leonetti leur donne un rôle
contraignant mais surtout elle accorde
un nouveau droit la sédation profonde et
continue jusqu'au décès c'est à dire le
droit d'être endormi à la toute fin de
vie sous certaines conditions elle doit
être décidée via une procédure
collégiale le patient doit souffrir de
façon insupportable et son décès doit
être inévitable et imminent la loi ne
permet donc pas de donner activement la
mort au patient ni de leur en donner les
moyens
[Musique]
alors la loi est méconnue ce qui est
encore plus méconnue ce sont les
directives anticipées on va en parler
dans un instant avec vous Mathias
Savignac mais d'abord sédation profonde
en quoi ça diffère de l'euthanasie vous
docteur est-ce que vous diriez que c'est
différent je dirais que c'est
radicalement différent parce
qu'effectivement l'intentionnalité n'est
pas la même et je pense que c'est
impossible intentionnalité de qui
l'intentionnalité du médecin supposait
répondre à l'intentionnalité du patient
et la sédation profonde des contenus
jusqu'au décès elle peut se faire soit
parce qu'un patient décide lui-même que
ses souffrances sont intolérables et
réfractaires on lui demande pas de le
prouver on lui demande simplement de le
dire donc c'est son sa volonté son
appréciation et derrière une demande
d'être endormie jusqu'à son décès avec
effectivement potentiellement une
ritualisation parce que l'intérêt de la
sédation qui est un droit c'est de
pouvoir effectivement l'exercer de
manière programmée écrite etc est-ce que
la sédation profonde elle est demandée
par le patient ou est-ce que c'est le
médecin qui décide à un certain stade de
l'évolution du malade dans un centre de
soins palliatifs à ce moment-là il est
éligible à la sédation profonde alors
les deux ont le droit de le demander le
premier cas quand c'est le patient qu'il
demande son souffrance intolérable c'est
une première situation dans la deuxième
situation et le patient peut le demander
par ses directives personnes de
confiance ou lui-même le deuxième cas
c'est lorsque les médecins considèrent
que les traitements relèvent de
l'obstination des raisonnable et qu'à ce
moment-là d'accord en même temps que la
décision collégiale une induction d'une
sédation la sédation profonde monsieur
Denis est-ce que finalement ça n'est pas
la réponse la réponse à l'aspiration
d'en finir quand il voilà quand le corps
n'en peut plus ça peut être une réponse
après il y a un grand débat sur la
sédation dans l'article 4 de la loi
classic il expliquait que la sédation
peut également abréger la vie c'est
clairement écrit la sédation et
l'existait avant 2016 elle existe depuis
bien longtemps la sédation simplement la
sédation de 2016 qui est maintenue et
continue jusqu'au décès à définir les
souffrances réfractaires il pronostic
vital imaginons on l'avait tellement
bien dit ce pronostic vit à la court
terme dans la loi de 2016 qu'il a fallu
attendre 2018 pour que l’autorité de
santé nous dise ces quelques heures
quelques jours mais ça peut être une
réponse oui mais ce n'est pas
aujourd'hui la seule réponse attendue
vous pouvez partir très rapidement d'une
sédation aujourd'hui vous avez aussi des
sessions qui durent des dizaines de
jours c'est ce que le Conseil d'été
appelle les mourants qui nous finissent
plus de mourir donc il y a une question
à poser qui est une éventuelle ouverture
du champ des possibles et c'est là où on
retrouve la légalisation de la désactive
à mourir et on va en parler dans un
instant restant un instant encore sur
les soins palliatifs l'objectif
prioritaire des soins palliatifs c'est
de soulager les personnes en fines en
fin de vie de leur souffrance je
voudrais qu'on regarde ce que font les
soignants par exemple à l'Institut de la
Verrière dans les Yvelines
un institut qui dépend de la MGEN
[Musique]
et les douleurs du ventre il y en a où
il y en a plus
de douleur vous êtes bien réconfortable
bon ben c'est bien ça
c'était quand même l'objectif premier de
votre arrivée
[Musique]
c'est un médicament qui aide à se
détendre
la plage se découvre et puis il y a
peut-être des choses qui réparaissent
bon ben c'est un peu ça donc on peut
parfois reparler d'autres choses une
fois que les plaintes sont apaisées
d'autres éléments importants c'est qu'on
arrive à s'intéresser aux patients je
pense que ça ils le voient et qu'on
parle autre chose que de sa maladie ou
des choses qu'il embête les médecins ils
soignent aussi les patients quand ils
donnent pas forcément de médicaments
mais plus parce qu'il parle et qui
prennent soin des gens
[Musique]
concernant le terrestre parce que
bon évidemment c'est extraordinairement
touchant cette sollicitude c'est du soin
c'est du soin ça pourquoi ne serait-ce
pas du sang je vous pose la question je
crois quelque chose qui répond à une
demande de soulagement d'un patient
c'est du soin et c'est de
l'accompagnement après je voudrais juste
dire une chose par rapport aux soins
palliatifs parce que c'est un point
important lorsqu'on parle de soins
palliatifs on ne sait jamais très bien
si on parle du soin en tant que contenu
du soin c'est-à-dire du traitement des
symptômes et de l'anticipation de la fin
de vie ou si on parle de personnel
d'acteurs de soins qui peuvent être
éventuellement les acteurs des unités
spécialisés et les soins palliatifs
c'est tout un continuum qui commence par
des cas non complexes qui commencent par
de la prise en charge qui peut être
celle du généraliste celle du médecin
hospitalier de base du moment qu'il est
formé et ça c'est un point important
parce que quand on ne parle de soins
palliatifs que pour parler des soins
extrêmement complexes on va parler de
soi auquel tout le monde n'a pas accès
parce qu'il y en a pas partout mais
aussi parce que tout le monde en a pas
besoin et je pense que cette distinction
dans les soins palliatifs c'est tous
français ont le droit aux soins
palliatifs en termes de contenu de soins
tous les Français fort heureusement pour
eux n'auront pas forcément besoin des
soins palliatifs réservés au traitement
complexes qui sont ceux qu'on a dans les
unités de soins palliatifs ce point-là
est important parce que ça permet de
comprendre toute la logique de
l'anticipation palliatif l'anticipation
palettitive étant la capacité à discuter
le plus tôt possible avec le patient de
comment ça se passerait si ça se passait
pas bien et ça ça peut être des mois ou
des années avant et c'est ça qui va
permettre qu'on est des soins palliatifs
au bon moment et au bon niveau c'est
intéressant alors justement vous
m'amenez sur le chemin des directives
anticipées à propos d'anticipation et je
voulais en parler avec vous Mathias
Savignac parce que c'était une avancée
importante de la loi les directives
anticipées pour résumer c'est la
capacité que nous avons tous
individuellement de mettre noir sur
blanc la façon dont nous voulons être
accompagnés ou pas
si on est malade à la fin de vie à des
moments où on pourrait plus avoir ce
libre arbitre vous je vais vous les avez
écrites vous directives anticipez alors
aujourd'hui est-ce que les Français ne
savent pas que ça existe je crois alors
c'est du droit existant qui est très peu
mis en oeuvre finalement et aujourd'hui
14% des Françaises et des Français ont
rédigé leur directives anticipées et je
fais partie des 86% qui ne l'ont pas
fait par ailleurs je porte le discours
de de faire connaître ses dispositifs là
mais j'avoue ne pas l'avoir fait pour
moi-même après il y a une chose qu'il
est importante de noter c'est que les
directives anticipées sont pas les
dernières volontés les directives
anticipées fixent ce qu'un patient peut
demander ou ne pas vouloir dans le cadre
de questions préétablies définies comme
le respirateur artificiel le fait d'être
réanimé ou pas et ça marche dans le cas
où la personne qui prend en charge un
patient à connaissance des directives
anticipées et bien souvent dans des
situations d'urgence il n'y a pas la
capacité matérielle à accéder à
l'information mais au-delà de ça donc il
s'agit pas tout seul dans son coin
d'écrire oui je voudrais bénéficier de
l'aide active à mourir si besoin était
c'est beaucoup plus précis que ça donc
et alors on va sur un site j'imagine si
on fait directives anticipées on peut
trouver les questions très facilement
mais que 14% des Français l'ont fait
c'est dommage parce que comment faire en
sorte qu'il s'approprient précisément
cette liberté Jonathan Denis de
communication et puis Mathias parlait
finalement du fichier parce que c'était
ça le fichier national comment prendre
connaissance des directives anticipées
rendez-vous compte dans la loi de 2016
une nouvelle fois il y a un article qui
dit il faut créer ce fichier national
des directives anticipés c'est la DMD
qu'il le gère gracieusement
notre association accompagnons les
Français les médecins généralistes ont
un travail à faire soit directement
anticipé vous les faites pas sur un coin
de table devant la télé ce soir on nous
regardant c'est une discussion
évidemment à avoir avec les proches une
discussion à voir avec des des soignants
c'est compliqué de se projeter moi je
les ai rédigés mais c'est très compliqué
de se projeter donc il faut créer ce
fichier pour que tous les soignants
puissent en avoir connaissance et
surtout bien réfléchir aussi à la
désignation d'une personne de confiance
malgré cette loi qui a quand même eu des
avancées vous même vous le reconnaissez
les soins palliatifs on verra tout à
l'heure que malheureusement on en
dispose pas partout en France c'est une
des difficultés mais malgré cela le
député à r.e.m Jean-Louis torrent auteur
d'une proposition de loi pour faire
évoluer précisément le statut court à
cette formule a eu cette formule qui est
souvent reprise on meurt mal aujourd'hui
en France on meurt mal aujourd'hui en
France vous partagez d'ailleurs cette ce
constat Jean-Louis torrent Mathias
Savignac mourir mal c'est une formule un
peu forte mais qu'elle mérite de pouvoir
souligner le fait qu'il y a des carences
aujourd'hui dans notre capacité à
prendre en charge les les le grand âge
d'une manière générale et la fin de vie
particulièrement évidemment le fait
qu'il y ait un manque important d'accès
pour les Françaises et les Français aux
soins palliatifs peuvent laisser penser
que finalement il y a une inégalité de
prise en charge et de traitement face à
la mort ou en tout cas la perspective de
mourir que
le fait de ne pas pouvoir
accéder à ces dispositifs peut faire que
parfois on meurt pas dans des conditions
de soulagement de la douleur ou
d'accompagnement le plus optimum mais je
crois que c'est une question globale la
fin de vie ne se résume pas
nécessairement aux dernières instants de
la vie il y a aussi la campagnement on
évoquait tout à l'heure les EHPAD ou la
prise en charge au long cours je pense
que c'est tout une chaîne de prise en
charge d'accompagnement qu'il faut
arriver à repenser pour respecter au
mieux la volonté de chacune et de chacun
alors je voudrais qu'on regarde à
nouveau un extrait d'un film qui a été
consacré aux soins palliatifs donc quand
on parle des soins palliatifs il y a les
patients on les a vu tout à l'heure et
elle est soignant et les soignants sont
parfois
réticents a participé à être actif dans
l'aide à mourir on comprend bien mais
parfois il y a les patients aussi qui
trouvent le temps long même dans les
soins palliatifs même ils sont quand ils
sont très très accompagnés ils trouvent
que ça ne va pas assez vite regardez
institut de La Verrière dans les
Yvelines
[Musique]
la mort depuis que je me bats contre le
cancer elle est dans moi elle est ma
compagne de toutes les jours de tous les
nuits c'est elle qui va apprivoiser elle
m'a dit mais je suis pas chez téléphone
qu'ils veulent bien dire maintenant je
veux me reposer
mais je croyais que ça allait quand même
aller plus vite ça veut dire qu'on vous
bichonne alors c'est ça
[Musique]
ce que ça montre là c'est que d'abord
c'est assez extraordinaire cette quand
on quand on voit les patients qui
bénéficient des soins palliatifs
on trouve ça quand même merveilleux de
pouvoir bénéficier mais même dans ces
cas-là certains trouvent la vie trop
longue donc on se pose la question de
l'aide active à mourir qu'est-ce qu'il
vous fera beau aujourd'hui docteur
Dauchy dans les soins palliatifs
je voudrais juste répondre je vais
répondre à votre question je voudrais
juste répondre sur un point important on
a parlé de déficit d'informations le
Centre national des soins palliatifs et
de la fin de vie est un organisme sur
financement public qui a été précisément
créé en 2016 pour favoriser
l'information des citoyens donc pas
simplement des signaux des citoyens
patients proches et citoyens
heureusement nos malades et la propriété
des lois donc il y a effectivement un
lieu prévu pour cela et par ailleurs
effectivement la majeure partie des
Français ne connaissent pas les
directives anticipées mais dans le
sondage auquel je faisais référence tout
à l'heure on leur a demandé où est-ce
qu'il souhaitait au mieux confier leur
préférence sur leur fin de vie et il y
en a environ 10% seulement qui parle de
le confier à une fiche de une fiche
sécurisée donc c'est juste un point dont
on pardonnerait un pas en arrière mais
c'est important là encore parce que je
reviens sur votre question les soins
palliatifs les soins palliatifs c'est
avant tout essayer de s'en créer sur la
volonté du patient et quand on dit soins
palliatifs dit forcément un système de
soins qui doit largement intégrer ce
recueil des volontés et des attentes ce
qui veut dire du temps du contact avec
les proches et tout un travail et encore
une fois il y a du boulot
vous parlez de la propriété par les
Français alors les Français quand on
leur pose la question ils sont
favorables mais de façon très massive on
le sait à ce que font évoluer la loi
vous avez fait un sondage
parifop ils sont pour un changement à
92%. 92%, c'est-à-dire quand on pose la
question dans la rue ou français avec
des méthodes de sondage de façon
scientifique ils sont favorables à ce
qu'on allait d'active à mourir en
situation de maladies graves et
incurable qu'est-ce que ça recouvre
madame
se prend dit ce chiffre est-ce que ça
veut dire que nous sommes collectivement
prêts à une légalisation de l'aide
active à mourir alors oui je pense que
oui la réponse est oui mais en général
et ça se voit aussi dans le monde
c'est-à-dire que ce n'est pas un hasard
un moment donné il y a des mouvements
sociétaux qui émergent il y a des
besoins qui émergent et on les voit
émerger en ce moment j'en suis pas
politique ça c'est ma première question
mais je voudrais je voudrais rebondir un
peu sur ce qui a été dit tout à l'heure
et votre question précédente sur les
choix palliatifs c'est-à-dire que un des
problèmes actuels c'est de voir toujours
une une opposition entre les soins
palliatifs et
une aide à mourir et ça c'est c'est
dommageable parce que voilà on a
l'impression qu'il y a une lutte tout le
monde ne va pas demander l'euthanasie
c'est une façon différente de mourir et
je reviens au problème de l'anticipation
même pour des gens qui sont en soins
palliatifs et qui trouvent le temps long
alors c'est beaucoup dans cette
temporalité parce que c'est ça au fond
l'euthanasie c'est une façon d'anticiper
d'abréger alors que un autre sens de
soins palliatifs
[Musique]
depuis qu'on a commencé à apprendre
attache auprès de nos adhérents nos
parties prenantes aux militants à
l'interne on a reçu beaucoup de courrier
d'adhérents qui nous témoignent de leur
situation et notamment j'ai en tête
une adhérente en Polynésie qui nous a
écrit pour dire qu'elle passait quelle
transitait par la France pour aller en
Belgique et donc elle a fait 12000 km
pour aller mourir loin de chez elle
atteinte de la maladie de Charcot
pourtant sur place prise en charge par
hospitalisation à domicile avec les
soins les accompagnements les
psychologues qui lui permettaient de
soulager ces souffrances et pour autant
elle ne voulait pas continuer de vivre
dans cette situation là et donc je
trouve je trouve souvent particulier de
devoir faire 12000 km loin des siens
pour aller pour aller trouver une
réponse un exemple effectivement très
frappant mais néanmoins en faisant moins
de kilomètres il y en a de plus en plus
de Français qui vont en Belgique vous
savez bien monsieur Denis et nous avons
suivi précisément le fils d'une femme
qui avait fait ce choix d'aller en
Belgique pour se donner la mort après
avoir été diagnostiquée évidemment d'une
maladie grave regarde reportage
[Musique]
un sourire jusqu'à la dernière seconde
c'est l'image que Nicolas gardera de sa
mère
euthanasier l'année dernière en Belgique
elle sait qu'elle va partir dans
quelques minutes
et là cette sérénité elle sait qu'elle y
est arrivée parce que vraiment son but
c'était de partir comme ça partir
heureuse partir en pleine possession de
son cerveau de son âme
vous qui était une femme forte comment
témoigne ses albums Johnny émigré du
Monténégro ingénieur dans les
télécommunications une femme brillante
qui choisit de décider de sa mort
lorsqu’un jour un cancer la condamne ça
a toujours été une évidence je pense
pour elle et moi j'en étais pas étonné
évidemment de voir qu'elle refusait de
de devenir légume quoi il voulait pas
perdre déjà son autonomie et ensuite
effectivement sa personnalité son âme en
quelque sorte
comme vous qui les Françaises sont de
plus en plus nombreux à les mourir à
l'étranger là où l'euthanasie est
autorisé à la frontière belge une
bénévole française se dévoue depuis 30
ans pour aider les patients à s'y
repérer
comme tous les jours Claudette reçoit de
nombreux appels à l'aide
[Musique]
je comprends
de lui il m'a dit moi c'est négatif il
peut aller passer une consultation alors
quand je dis une consultation c'est deux
consultations à Bruxelles et après son
dossier est ouvert en Belgique Claudette
fait d'abord un premier tri puis
lorsqu'elle juge que les patients
rentrent dans le cadre légal elle les
oriente vers un médecin belge qui
accepte de les aider
avec le temps Claudette est un peu
devenu sa secrétaire médicale
bonjour
Yves le docteur Delock est un habitué
des euthanasies de français il n'existe
aucune donnée officielle mais comme lui
les médecins belges remarquent une
augmentation des demandes
un seul hôpital qui accepte d'être
étrangers
par semaine pour moi c'est trop au
départ avec le dette on avait dit une
par mois je me vois mal comme la loi
classe Léo la
dire à un patient vous n'avez pas encore
souffert assez souffert revenez l'année
prochaine le patient quand il sait que
son dossier est ouvert et qui pourra
peut-être un jour
bénéficier d'une euthanasie ce sont
beaucoup mieux quand ils quittent mon
bureau il y en a parfois qui avait
arrêté leur traitement qui reprennent
leur traitement le docteur de Locke
prendra sa retraite prochainement pour
continuer à soulager les patients
Claudette compte sur une évolution de la
loi française qui espère-elle pourrait
s'inspirer des dispositions belges
[Musique]
voilà extrait d'un reportage d'Alexia le
perron pour état de santé vous voyez
réagir docteur Dechy vous allez nous
dire mais d'abord Mathias Savignac
qu'est-ce que ça vous inspire le début
de la vidéo m'inspire quelque chose qui
me semble aussi assez intéressant à
savoir que il est éminemment important
de s'intéresser à la volonté des
patients dans ce qu'ils souhaitent
qu'ils ne souhaitent pas s'intéresser à
ceux qui partent et je trouve que le
début de la vidéo mentionne aussi ce qui
reste et que finalement
pouvoir prévoir sa fin de vie comme
c'est le cas avec l'euthanasie permet
aussi à celles et ceux qui restent de
dire au revoir à leurs proches et de
faire de ce moment-là un moment de vie
jusqu'au bout et c'est important pour
faire le deuil et garder ce lien vous
permettez juste que je propose à
Jonathan Denis de nous raconter aussi
l'histoire que vous avez vécu avec votre
père c'est une histoire comme c'était
relatée aussi dans le reportage mon père
avait un cancer généralisé mon père
était parti d'un principe simple quand
les souffrances sont insupportables pour
lui il m'avait demandé une promesse
c'était de la compagnie jusqu'au bout
jusqu'au bout pour lui société prendre
un médicament qui lui permettait de
partir et ce médicament ne l'a pas aidé
à partir c'est pour ça qu'il y a
peut-être aussi des modèles qui sont à
questionner sur la dette qui va mourir
comme le modèle de l'Orégon on prend
cela médicament c'est ce qui s'était
passé pour mon père aux États-Unis ou la
personne qui est éligible peut aller
chercher un médicament à lui de le
prendre ou pas d'ailleurs c'est très
intéressant parce que certains ne le
font finalement pas ne le font pas et
pour plus de la moitié le fond avec des
conséquences qui peuvent être aussi
terribles mon père l'a pris seul et a
été transporté à l'hôpital il a fallu
connaître le bon entre guillemets chef
de service qui connaissait mon père qui
avait compris la demande de mon père et
qu'il l'a accompagné jusqu'au bout
jusqu'au bout c'était une euthanasie
clandestine puisqu'aujourd'hui il y a
des euthanasies clandestines qui se font
chez nous aujourd'hui il y a des
Français qui paient pour aller en Suisse
il y a des Français qui légalement vont
en Belgique en se faisant
ça coûte cher parce que ça relève aussi
l'égalité de soi en Suisse ça coûte
10000 euros mais c'est le coût d'un
suicide assisté en Belgique vous vous
faites alors il y a des Français qui se
font remboursé en Belgique les soins
préparatoires du euthanasie par la
Sécurité Sociale française parce qu'ils
sont transfrontaliers
tout à l'heure ce qui me fait régime je
vais réagir rapidement à certains points
le Centre national comme j'ai dit tout à
l'heure est une structure publique par
définition non militante donc c'est pas
là-dessus que je vais je vais rebondir
en revanche c'est un centre de
ressources et de référence et c'est des
informations je voudrais donner
lorsqu'on dit la loi qui est Unity les
personnes non il faut attendre que les
personnes souffrent assez pour demander
à bénéficier de la sédation c'est inexa
l'arrêt des soins et demandables par
absolument tout patient qui considère
qu'ils sont déraisonnables et la loi
classique prévoit que si jamais l'arrêt
des traitements peut entraîner le décès
avec des souffrances la sédation
profonde et continue doit être mise en
place et juste pour rajouter deux mots
les soins quand on dit les soins
palliatifs ne veulent pas de changement
de la loi c'est la même la même
erreur d'interprétation si je peux me le
permettre que je mentionner tout à
l'heure c'est les soins palliatifs en
tant qu'acteur pas les soins palliatifs
en termes de contenu de soins les soins
palliatifs ce sont un contenu de soins
ce ne sont pas des personnes et je crois
qu'il faut faire très attention à ces
raccourcis là ça n'a pas de sens
d'opposer un contenu de soins avec une
volonté de changer un texte de loi on
parle de concept totalement différent et
alors les soins palliatifs ils n'ont pas
disparaître si la loi évolue tout ça va
évidemment coexister on aura des choix
supplémentaires on s'intéresse à ce que
faisait nos voisins parce qu'on va en
Belgique on va en Suisse donc on a des
voisins qui ont légiféré plutôt que nous
qui a fait quoi regardez cette
infographie
[Musique]
6 c'est le nombre de pays parmi nos
voisins européens qui autorisent l'aide
actives à mourir les Pays-Bas et la
Belgique font figurent de précurseurs
cela fait 20 ans que les médecins ils
sont autorisés à donner la mort aux
patients qui le souhaitent au Pays-Bas
un texte promulgué le premier avril 2001
autorise le tanasier et le suicide
assisté aux personnes qui sont capables
de discernement qui expriment leur
demande de manière volontaire et
mûrement réfléchies qui sont atteintes
d'une maladie incurable qui subissent
une souffrance physique ou psychique
insupportable et sans perspective
d'amélioration et ce s'il n'y a aucune
autre option réaliste un médecin et un
expert indépendant doivent attester du
respect des critères d'éligibilité les
conditions d'accès sont similaires en
Belgique et encadrés par la loi du 28
mai 2002 la demande doit être de plus
répétée par écrit et lors d'entretien
avec un médecin le patient peut exprimer
ses volontés dans une déclaration
anticipée ou en faire la demande express
en 2014 la Belgique a élargi l'accès à
l'euthanasie aux enfants capacité de
discernement
en Suisse la loi qui encadre l'aide
active à mourir est encore plus ancienne
elle date de 1942 mais notorise que le
suicide assisté et non l'euthanasie à la
fin du processus souvent accompagné par
une association c'est donc le patient
qui se donne la mort lui-même en prenant
un médicament
en 2009 le Luxembourg a rejoint la liste
des pays qui autorisent l'euthanasie et
le suicide assisté et a été suivi en
2021 par l'Espagne dans les prochains
mois le Portugal pourrait devenir le
cinquième pays européen légaliser
l'euthanasie
la loi sur la mort médicalement assistée
a bien été adopté au Parlement le 9
décembre 2022 mais elle se heurte à
l'opposition du président portugais
[Musique]
alors vers quel modèle devrait-on aller
Jonathan Denis on serait capable en
France de faire un modèle 100% français
mais il y a plusieurs modèles qui sont
interrogés le modèle de la Belgique où
ils ont fait trois lois soit un
palliatif droit des patients et des
pénalisations de l'euthanasie il y a
effectivement le modèle espagnol il y a
le modèle italien c'est aussi assisté
vous avez le modèle de l'Orégon donc je
parlais dont je parlais tout à l'heure
qui pour moi ne serait pas un modèle
s'inscrivant dans la promesse de
solidarité d'autonomie de fraternité
peut avoir que peut avoir notre pays
mais la France saura faire un modèle
c'est bien le but aussi de cette
convention citoyenne c'est de réfléchir
sur ce qui peut exister à l'étranger et
sur la façon dont pourrait évoluer la
loi en France vous nous voyez aucune
réserve vous n'avez aucune critique à
faire au système belge par exemple
certains estiment que une fois qu'on a
fait sa demande comment on le voyait
dans le reportage à l'extia le père en
tout à l'heure une fois qu'on a on est
entré dans le processus et bien on ne
peut plus en sortir une espèce de
pression qui s'opère sur l'individu
demandeur qui fait qu'on ne peut plus
finalement on a perdu le libre choix
qu'on pensait exercer par la par cette
même démarche c'est bien le passé
c'est le médecin qui consomme et
jusqu'au bout dans tous les pays
jusqu'au bout à la dernière seconde on
vous demande de ce que vous souhaitez
évidemment vous avez des personnes qui
en Belgique ne vont pas au bout mais il
faut bien comprendre que ça rassure
aussi les patients de savoir que ça
existe et c'est pour ça que parfois ils
ne vont pas au bout et ils vont décider
ils vont décéder pardon d'une mort
naturelle c'est ce qu'on appelle le
phénomène chez des amis du terme de
phénomène de la porte de sortie ça
rassure que infini en soit respecté dans
ses volontés c'est intéressant ça le
fait de savoir que ça existe peut
dissuader certains qui peut-être
auraient été hantée aurait été tenté de
le faire si ça n'existe pas alors pour
qui pour qui faut-il éventuellement
légiférer pour quelle maladie
les le Comité consultatif national
d'éthique a pointé certaines situations
dans lesquelles la loi actuelle ne
répondait pas au désir des patients et
notamment a mis en avant l'exemple des
maladies neurodégénératives
c'est l'exemple le plus habituellement
mis en avant juste un chiffre par
rapport à ça parce qu'on parlait de
l'Orégon les malades atteints avant
qu'il ne soit plus en situation
évidemment de demander oui si ce n'est
que lorsqu'ils ne sont plus en situation
de demander ils sont en général en
situation d'être dépendantes d'une
suppléance vitale et je vous rappelle
que la loi française autorise absolument
tous les patients à demander l'arrêt des
traitements juste un chiffre en Oregon
c'est intéressant le nombre de patients
la proportion des patients atteints de
sclérose latérales la myotrophique qui
décède par recours au suicide assisté et
de 5% de cette population ce qui est
intéressant et pour ça que ça dit quoi
ça dit que c'est plus c'est une
proportion plus importante que celle des
autres pathologies c'est moins de 1%
pour les patients atteints de cancer ça
dit en même temps que ce n'est pas ce
n'est pas forcément parce que la loi
existe que c'est la seule solution pour
ces patients là mais c'est une donnée
factuelle sans qui n'a pas d'autre sens
que ça donnait factuel Mathias Savignac
pour qui pour qui parce que c'est une
question aussi très importante si on
fait évoluer la loi pour quel type de
malade est-ce que les jeunes par exemple
pour être exercées ce droit ça aussi
c'est une question très sensible je sais
pas vous répondre Elizabeth je sais pas
parce qu'à titre personnel je peux avoir
des convictions des idées mais je trouve
que c'est le genre de de
questions auxquelles il faut apporter
une réponse collective et je trouve qu'à
ce titre là la convention citoyenne qui
est formidable exercice de démocratie
permet aussi d'éclairer la manière dont
celles et ceux qui vont prendre la
décision le feront et encore une fois je
[Musique]
voilà ça fait ça fait c'est la grande
majorité des cas mais ce sont les cas
moins problématiques du fait que le
décès est prévisible l'écart les plus
problématiques c'est les cas du
polyhandicap
complexe parce que là il faut évaluer
non
handicap sont pronostic vital engagé
voilà c'est ça et de quels
majorité des gens qui le demandent aussi
c'est pour des raisons de dépendance
mais comme le disent aussi j'ai lu
témoignage Suisse et belges et lycée les
cas les plus complexes à évaluer donc je
pense parce que la souffrance certes
c'est celle du patient mais elle doit
être approuvée par les médecins donc je
pense que dans une loi probablement mais
moi je suis d'accord avec ce quasiment
oui ça vient que
une loi doit être déterminée
démocratiquement et non seulement ça
mais elle va évoluer les lois dans les
autres pays ont évolué il s'agit pas de
ne pas changer et ce n'est pas figé et
on n'a pas arrêté de faire évoluer les
lois sur l'IVG sur l'assistance médicale
la procrasion et donc il faut pas se
figer là-dessus il faut commencer par
quelque chose qui habitent aussi qui
crée un nouveau écosystème de la mort
pour voir comment ce système à la
française va se mettre en place et va
pouvoir évoluer ce qui craindrait que on
enferme la France dans un effectivement
un cadre il faut comprendre que ça peut
encore évoluer il y a une chose dont on
a encore pas parlé pourtant elle est
évidente dans ce débat on essaye dans la
limite du temps dont on dispose de de ne
rater aucune problématique c'est
évidemment celle des soignants soigner
c'est guérir sincèrement d'Hippocrate or
là on engage le soignant dans une
démarche très différente et évidemment
il y a des réticences c'est une question
qu'on a posé au médecin gériatres
Jacques Weber dans un service de soins
palliatifs écouté
[Musique]
est-ce que toutes les demandes doivent
être suivies des faits en tout cas je
pense qu'il y a des réflexions éthiques
à mener après vous dire moi à titre
personnel comment je me positionnerai si
jamais il y avait une évolution de la
loi je sais pas si moi je demanderai pas
avoir un droit au retrait pour avoir mon
libre arbitre dans la décision
[Musique]
le droit au retrait un acteur c'est quoi
c'est invoqué la cause de conscience et
dire moi je ne veux pas en être je ne
veux pas faire ce type de geste les
guerres de mes patients c'est laisser au
médecin sa liberté aussi mais enfin ça
pose la question sous-jacente ça renvoie
l'éternel question sous-jacent de quelle
compréhension de ce qui est en train de
se passer qu'elle compréhension de
l'acte par exemple on disait tout à
l'heure là ça veut dire quoi c'est à
quel comporte on disait on parlait tout
à l'heure de la sélection profonde et
continuer et du fait qu'elle pouvait
abréger le décès très clairement on n'a
pas de chiffres montrons que la sédation
en elle-même abrège le décès en revanche
la sédation est en systématiquement
associée à un arrêt des traitements et
notamment un arrêt l’hydratation et
l'alimentation effectivement un patient
s'est daté va mourir plus vite qu'un
patient qu'on n'aura pas ses daté et je
parle de savoir ce qu'on fait parce que
typiquement devant une sédation profonde
et continue jusqu'au décès il y a encore
des médecins qui se demandent s'ils ne
sont pas d'abréger la vie donc la
question sous-jacente de celle de la
clause de retraite de de la clause de
conscience comme celle de l'intégralité
des actes en soins palliatifs pose la
question de avec quelle formation on le
fait avec quelle relation avec son
médecin et avec quelle capacité à
anticiper pas au sens de d'accélérer le
décès quand je parle des anticipations
tout à l'heure c'est pas ça c'est anti
anticipé pardon au sens d'être capable
de reconnaître que la médecine de guerra
pas forcément et que être médecin c'est
être capable très tôt de dire peut-être
on va pas y arriver alors ça ce sont des
débats effectivement extraordinairement
passionnant que les médecins la
communauté médicale est évidemment très
concernée par par tout ça très
bouleversé sans doute aussi la clause de
conscience est une évidence ou pas
on peut parler de libre choix et
demander aux soignants et aux médecins
de devoir absolument pratiquer quelque
chose qui pourrait ne pas être dans leur
valeur ou bien même qui pourrait être
dans leur valeur mais ils ne
souhaiterait pas le faire on entend une
témoignage du docteur Yves deloch en
Belgique il vous expliquer la dureté de
de faire ce geste d'euthanasie donc vous
pouvez être favorable une évolution de
la loi être favorable une euthanasie et
de soignant et ne pas souhaité le faire
donc la clause de conscience c'est
indéniablement la clé de voûte du projet
de loi pour respecter chacun dans ses
convictions nous réfléchissons une
quarantaine de minutes ensemble les
membres de la Convention citoyenne ça
fait des semaines qu'ils sont en train
de plancher sur ce débat et sont donc
185 ils vous ont peut-être d'ailleurs
entendu madame Dechy madame vous avez
peut-être été entendu aussi par les
membres de la Convention citoyenne
certains sont arrivés avec des
certitudes très ancrées ils sortent avec
que des questions on va écouter
quelques-unes de leur réflexion et on se
retrouve juste après
[Musique]
les citoyens vont se réunir à raison de
9 séquences c'est plus de 24 jours de
travail il y a des auditions il y a une
formation un accompagnement des outils
qui seront proposés on a toujours
l'impression que les citoyens sont pas
capables de faire des choses et en fait
quand on leur donne les clés les outils
et l'accompagnement nécessaire pour le
faire la délibération collective elle
produit des choses formidables le
premier sujet c'est santé on va devoir
aborder des questions morales et
éthiques qu'est-ce que la société veut
est-ce que oui ou non on veut telle ou
telle pratique par exemple sur le
recours à l'euthanasie aux soucis
d'assister est-ce que oui ou non on a
tous des expériences de fin de vie ayant
une maladie évolutive j'ai peur qu'un
jour je me retrouve dans un lit puisse
avoir marché et qu'on doit s'occuper de
moi
[Musique]
c'est pas possible pour moi c'est juste
pas possible du tout du tout du tout du
tout du tout
l'audition des soignants où là on a eu
une quasi uneanimité des soignants donc
médecins infirmières accompagnant
contre le tanasie
ouais ça je peux le dire moi ça m'a ça
m'a bouleversé ça m'interpelle quand
même sur des choses que j'avais pas
imaginé
[Musique]
l'ouverture de cette porte parce qu'il y
aura des dérives c'est sûr et certain
groupe qui finalement se sont
positionnés différemment oui
pour avoir droit avec les soufflets
après cette sessions on se rend compte
que c'est beaucoup plus compliqué que ça
et que il y a plein de d'aspérités à
prendre en compte plein de chaque fin de
vie est différente et en fait la
question est pas si simple que ça
[Musique]
oui c'est beaucoup plus compliqué que ça
effectivement Mathias il faut rappeler
que certains pensent que deux de cet
exercice démocratique dont vous parliez
va sortir une loi pas du tout il va ce
sont des avis de citoyens qui vont
éclairer ensuite le législateur et a
commencé aussi par par l'Élysée par
Emmanuel Macron qui a demandé la loi
elle viendra après bien sûr c'est une
forme d'éclairage c'est une forme de
délibération qui permet finalement de
prendre le pouls de la société à travers
des citoyennes et des citoyens qui avec
ce qu'ils sont leurs singularité
ensemble se forment une un avis
collectif qui n'a pas valeur de loi mais
qui va valeur d'éclairage pour celles et
ceux qui auront la responsabilité de
voter ou pas une loi autour de l'aide
d'active à mourir alors c'est un bel
exemple quand même parce que on est
rendu à beaucoup de modestie une fois
que on vous reçoit les uns et les autres
pour expliquer vos pratiques même
principe qu'est-ce que vous attendez de
cette convention citoyenne alors moi je
suis frappée par par le fait que le
moment auquel ça a été fait et le fait
que on a on en a parlé tout à l'heure on
a l'impression que quelque chose émerge
de nouveau dans la société est plutôt
que dans un tenir à des simples sondages
qui dépendent de la façon dont la
question est posée et bien on va
consolider cette cette opinion cette
opinion publique on peut dire d'une
façon plus structurée avec des citoyens
représentatifs mais qui ont été formés
et donc je pense que c'est en fait c'est
c'est une
ça donne à vraiment une indication
beaucoup plus fiable que nous leçons les
simples sondages de où nous en sommes
par rapport à la à la à la réflexion je
voulais rebondir aussi sur les soignants
peut-être sur le fait que je voulais
donner une statistique au Québec ou le
pourcentage des de ses décès par aide
médicale à mourir le plus élevé presque
5%, il y a que 0,5 presque 5%. c'est le
plus élevé par rapport à la Belgique
de tous les décès et
presque 5%. mais je voulais juste
rassurer les soignants il n'y a que
0,5% des soignants qui effectuent le
geste et donc on est même pas dans le
cadre d'une objection de conscience
c'est-à-dire une objection conscience on
est censé le faire et on se dégage c'est
une acte dérogatoire or là c'est
vraiment une volonté une liberté des
soignants qui le désirent de le faire
donc c'est très rassurant je trouve pour
les soignants on va j'imagine que
évidemment les membres de la Convention
citoyenne ont scruté de près tous les
exemples pas seulement européens y
compris le Québécois qu'elle est
intéressante il nous reste quelques
secondes qu'est-ce que vous attendez de
la convention citoyenne docteur qui l'on
ressortent ce qu'il ressort d'un espace
de pensée et de réflexion autour de
quelque chose qui fait aussi peur que la
fin de vie et ce qu'on ce à quoi on
assiste et la le centre est présent via
sa directrice je vais remercier
au sein de la convention citoyenne et ce
qu'elle décrit est un formidable
exercice démocratique mais surtout un
formidable exercice de mise en situation
et de mise en pensée d'une fin vie qui
habituellement fait tellement peur qu'on
arrive à un débat très binaire qui est
plutôt que de penser à ce qui fait peur
je vais pour où je suis contre et la
vraie question c'est comment on
structure une réflexion le plus en amont
possible et le plus pluriel possible
pour chacun forger sa fin de vie en
fonction de ses attentes et ses valeurs
je vais t'en donner juste pour conclure
en quelques mots vous n'avez jamais été
aussi prêt c'est votre état d'esprit
c'est votre sentiment de d'arriver ce à
quoi pour lequel vous militez depuis des
années j'espère que je me méfie parce
que des conventions citoyennes on a déjà
eu on parlait politique il y a déjà eu
une proposition de loi votant la
légalisation des actifs à mourir en
France c'était il y a deux ans et pour
autant c'était le cas d'une niche
parlementaire ils sont pas allés au bout
donc finalement oui aujourd'hui on
pourrait dire un alignement des planètes
maintenant il va falloir continuer à
discuter et raisonnablement optimiste si
la loi est votée je me méfie de
ensuite la mise en oeuvre vous avez
raison faut regarder tous les
compartiments du jeu merci infiniment
Jonathan Denis Alain spranzy docteur
Dechy merci beaucoup Mathias Savignac on
espère vous avoir éclairé en tout cas
aider à forger cet opinion encore une
fois délicate à se faire sur ce débat
sur la fin de vie c'est la fin de ce
numéro d'état de santé exceptionnel
bonne soirée à tous sur LCP
[Musique]